récemment au soir le contact
elle a dévalisé un magasin des coûts
délicieuse sa volaille maps est là moi
mon morceau était délicieux c'est un peu
sec tu pourrais dire aujourd'hui les
fêtes de noël on respire
comment on va survivre à noël on se
retrouve coincé à 12 dans une maison
sans chauffage et sans électricité le
champ bossu à plaindre est est à 4
servir alors ce sera une bière c'est
vraiment bizarre
les personnes à deux voitures raison de
plus pour s'inquiéter
qu'est ce que tu as vu la hausse
qui a fait ça
saint nicolas ne se montrera pas cette
année
à sa place viendra un esprit bien plus
ancien des traces de sabots donner l'or
ou d'un book qui avance sur ses pattes
arrière tu as déjà vu sa toile c'est
comme pour ceux
lui et ses acolytes ne sont pas venus
donner méprendre
on va faire une chaîne donnez vous la
main
c'est l'ombre de saint nicolas
tout va bien
et puis à noël ne peut rien arriver de
mal